appreciate and welcomes the
strong support technical allies and
partners have provided for Ukraine but
it also counts on us to continue to
support Ukraine in the future my message
to him was that NATO has stood by
Ukraine for a long time we will we
continue to stand by Ukraine as they
continue to repel the Russian aggression
against their country and we will stand
by Ukraine in the future
to help to build a better and brighter
future for the Ukrainian people
president zielinski and I also
discuss the preparations for the
upcoming NATO Summit in Vilnius in July
I have invited him to attend the meeting
and I'm glad that he has accepted the
invitation and will attend the NATO
Summit in Vilnius
um
we discussed the preparations and I
highlighted that
there are at least two issues that will
be important for Ukraine one is that I
expect
NATO allies at the summit to recommit to
support Ukraine for as long as it takes
with substantial Military Support to
ensure that Ukraine prevails as a
certain implementation in in Europe and
I also expect the NATO allies to agree a
multi-year program
to help Ukraine transition from
soviet-era equipment
standards doctrines to Nato standards
and doctrines and to ensure full
interoperability between Ukrainian
forces and NATO forces so I'm looking
for the meeting now and I'm ready to
answer your questions
get the road map of accession because a
lot of Ukrainian officials they said
that one condition of participants of
zelenskies roadmap
I said in Kiev yesterday and that
Ukraine's future is in the Euro Atlantic
family and all NATO allies have agreed
that Ukraine will become a NATO member
but the main focus now is of course on
uh on how to ensure that Ukraine
prevails what we do know is that our
support helps Ukraine move to move
toward
the Euro Atlantic integration and our
and our support help them to make this
this possible but the main focus now is
on ensuring that President Putin do not
does not win the award that Ukraine
prevails because without a sovereign
independent Ukraine there's no meaning
in discussing membership
he needed most you speak about what
weapons did he say he needed most well
uh he uh went to a different types of
weapons including everything from air
defense heavy armor Jets I'll leave it
to uh to minister esnikova and
ukrainians here to to describe exactly
what kind of needs they have but that's
the reason why it is important to meet
here in Ramstein to sit down with
ukrainians and to discuss in detail what
are the needs what are the gaps and how
can NATO allies and partners in the U.S
that contact could ensure that we are
providing them and the support they need
as soon as possible then in my
discussions with um
with a president
zelensky I of course
recognize the importance of discussing
new capabilities and the support for
Ukraine has evolved as the war has
evolved in the beginning the focus was
on light anti-tank weapons like the
javelins and the in-laws then the focus
also on artillery and then for a long
time the main focus was on air defense
and modern air defense systems like
Patriots and Nathans and I welcome the
fact that now there are patriots in
place German and U.S Patriots in place
in in Ukraine and over the last weeks we
have a lot of focus on focus on on armor
on battle tanks and battle tanks are now
coming into uh to Ukraine and we need to
continue to discuss and jets are also
being delivered by allies to to Ukraine
we need to continue to discuss specific
platforms but as important as discussing
new platforms it is extremely important
to ensure that all the platforms which
are already in Ukraine work and function
as they should meaning that we need
ammunition we need spare parts we need
fuel we need maintenance we need a pair
we need all the sustainment to ensure
that all the systems which are already
there are delivering the effect that
they should so therefore not only
discuss new systems but also discuss how
to ensure that existing systems function
so it's not to have a timetable when
Ukraine could enter mato
so all Naturals have agreed that Ukraine
will become a a member
president has a very clear
expectation we discussed this
both the issue of membership but also
security guarantees
um and um and of course Ukraine needs
security because no one can tell when
and how this war ends but what we do
know is that when the war ends we need
to ensure that history doesn't repeat
itself that Russia is not able to
continue to attack and to wage war again
against Ukraine and to continue to chip
away at the European security so we need
a discussion about a security framework
we need and there will be a discussion
about this ongoing discussion about a
membership but my message was
first Ukraine it's rightful place is in
NATO as allies have agreed
but also that the main focus now is to
ensure that Ukraine prevails because if
Ukraine doesn't Prevail as a Sovereign
Nation in Europe there is no meaning in
discussing membership and we need to
preserve the unity in supporting Ukraine
and that's the main focus also the
meeting today okay so long-term military
heads it means that the con the military
won't be enough and that we have to get
prepared to uh maybe many years before
the wars are by Nature unpredictable so
no one can tell today when this war ends
um hopefully the ukrainians are able to
make a lot of progress and and and and
you can have it just and and enduring
peace soon but no one can say that with
certainty so in need to be prepared for
the Long Haul and that's the reason why
NATO allies
has stated have stated again and again
and that we will stand by Ukraine for as
long as it takes but the other reason
why we need a kind of long-term
perspective is that even
or also after the war ends we need to
support Ukraine because you need to
ensure that Ukraine has the military
strength the capabilities the the
deterrence to prevent new attacks
because you have to remember that the
war didn't start in February last year
the war started in 2014 when
um Russia illegally Annex Crimea and
when Russia for the first time moved
into Eastern Don boss and then we had a
full-scale invasion in in February so
when the war ends we need to ensure that
it really ends and that is enduring
peace and to ensure that we also need
the long-term
engagement relationship with Ukraine and
that's the reason why we also look at a
more multi-air program package from NATO
to help to ensure full interoperability
with Ukrainian forces okay yeah
wondering about they they say that today
there's a meeting for the thanks groups
or something like this today and all the
information that we got that the tanks
is fourteen seven seven something like
this is that enough for Ukraine to win
in this uh War and the other question is
do you think Ukraine can win in this war
alone I mean just women's it's mean yes
I absolutely believe that and not least
because we have seen the Courage the
skills the determination of the Ukraine
Armed Forces President Putin made
several big mistakes strategic mistakes
when he invaded Ukraine the first was to
totally underestimate the the strength
of the Ukrainian Armed Forces he thought
that he was going to control a Ukraine
within weeks and and take a year within
days
then he totally underestimated
NATO allies and our partners in our
resolve to support Ukraine and therefore
he has now been in in Ukraine for more
than a year and he
just in no way control the country I see
a plan and ukrainians have been able to
push back
the the Russian forces around Kiev I was
a butcher yesterday and of course that
that was a city that was controlled by
Russian forces in the beginning of the
war liberated by the Ukrainian uh Armed
Forces after uh a month
um the Ukraine forces pushed back the
Russian forces in the East around hard
cave and then in in in in the South
around kaisan and we are now helping
them to liberate uh more land by
providing more advanced systems on the
battle tanks well first of all I think
you need to understand that
we speak about
many types of Battle Tanks but uh also
older ones but but now allies are
delivering a significant number of
advanced modern NATO standard battle
tanks like The Leopard 2 uh like the
Challenger from the United Kingdom the
Abrahams but in addition to the advanced
modern NATO standard battle tanks allies
are also delivering infantry fighting
Vehicles armed personnel carriers a lot
of armor and ammunition and equipment to
these so all of this is is really
Advanced high in capabilities that can
enable the ukrainians to push to the
Russian Airlines
sorry last one could you please
elaborate a little bit more of what are
your exact expectations for the outcome
of today's meeting also in terms of
threats
so first of all I would like to commend
the United States for a leading and
convening and this group the the the
defense contacted for Ukraine and also
for Germany to hosting it uh and uh and
and Minister Darius
um I expect that at this meeting
NATO allies Partners will announce
additional support and again not only
new platforms but also to sustain the
existing platforms
just to have the battle times you need
enormous amount of ammunition fuel
um
uh trailers to be able to move heavy
equipment like battle tanks
recovery Vehicles so I think sometimes
we underestimate all these Logistics
that have to be in place just to have a
operational tank battle tanks
capabilities so maybe it sounds a bit
more boring but the logistics is
extremely important this is now a battle
of attrition and a battle of attrition
becomes a
a war of logistics so uh so so so so so
therefore I I welcome all the
announcements I expect that will come
later today where all they had some
announcements the Netherlands and
Denmark have announced that they will
deliver 14 more leopard battle tanks the
U.S announced the more uh missile
Examination for hymers more than 300
million extra US Dollars announced
yesterday and all the other allies and
partners are announcing more on jet
well allies have uh delivered Poland
Slovakia has delivered um mig-29s
there's an ongoing discussion about uh
uh also other types of jets I will leave
that to the meeting here and also uh the
ongoing discussion among allies and
partners we need to constantly assess
concept the consult
but again not only about new platforms
but also sustaining all the platforms
you have
thank you so much thank you